a classified domestic surveillance
program operated by the TSA faces
criticism for tracking information from
American citizens who are not suspected
of committing any crimes
the Boston Globe first reported the
existence of this program CBS has now
confirmed how air marshals documents
certain passengers behavior including
whether they fidget use a computer or
have a jump in their Adam's apple Kris
Van Cleave is in Washington with more
details on that program Chris good
morning good morning the TSA is publicly
acknowledging this previously unreported
domestic surveillance program known as
quiet skies it uses a computer algorithm
to spot fliers whose recent travel
activities align with things like visits
to certain terror hotspots known terror
threats or people who are on watch lists
actions that may raise red flags
travelers identified by the computer are
then analyzed and vetted by a human team
if there are what sources described as
justifiable concerns that flier may be
surveilled by federal air marshals that
can include being followed at airports
and on flights and having their behavior
monitor and noted for suspicious
activity it does not include electronic
surveillance it is a program that some
air marshals have been highly critical
of TSA officials say the program
complies with security restraints and
privacy requirements in a statement the
agency says the program's primary
response is to it primary purpose is to
ensure passengers and flight crew are
protected during air travel adding it
does not take into account race and
religion and it is not intended to
surveil ordinary Americans fliers are
removed from the list if they go a
certain amount of time without incident
our sources claim the program is
relatively small currently affecting in
the range of dozens of Flyers Norah all
right Chris thank you